let me give you a warning i will not
give you this warning anymore in the
year okay um they're generally in a
group when it's the kind of group where
you have to provide input okay uh you
have to get involved
usually the easy things come at the
beginning of like the session or
whatever okay and the questions get
progressively harder because they rely
on previous stuff right so you know
usually people say like oh can someone
brainstorm things for you know whatever
topic the first one is obviously the
easiest because no one has said anything
yet so you can put in whatever simple
basic thing and it's like yes
that's great because no one else has
said anything okay now
today's lesson is no different okay so
i'm going to give you that warning if
you don't want to get in while it's easy
fine but i'll pick someone later on and
you might regret it
last chance anyone want to volunteer
what their sentence was yes
um
that's good this is a good start okay
let's go with this
okay the gradient increases at an
increasing rate okay which sure enough
it does okay what would it
do
if it was only increasing but at a
constant rate
what would it look like
what's going on hold on be careful your
language here this is why i asked you to
write it okay
the gradient is increasing
at an increasing rate that's what this
is
doing if the gradient is increasing at a
constant rate okay the gradient might be
one at a particular moment the next
moment it might be two if it was
increasing at a constant rate what would
it be at the next moment
it would be three and then four and then
five
does that look like a straight line to
you
no no that's not a straight line
now i'll let you have a think about this
by the way so i will get to the limit
question that i asked you yet that
actually
it was ruben you asked that didn't it
yeah he's not ridiculous okay
fine he gets no answer from me okay um
we will address that question but you're
gonna notice me doing this a lot okay um
i'm gonna give you questions and i'm
just gonna let them sit in your brains
because that's where they will give the
most benefit if i give you the answer
it's kind of like you know it's like
reading spoilers you're like oh okay
that's how it ends but it ruins the
experience you know so i'm going to do
that a lot
you actually know all of you know what
the function looks like if the grade is
increasing at a constant rate
you definitely know enough calculus to
work it out on your own what kind of
function is it you can be very specific
we'll get to that later on
now that's um that's as x approaches
positive infinity what's it doing on the
left hand side
what's it doing on the left-hand side
okay the gradient is now at this point
we have to be very careful
um
we're thinking about the left-hand side
we're saying the gradient is decreasing
stop what does that mean what does that
mean we're going from from this way to
the left
a lower gradient
means it's shallower isn't it okay and
that's true enough that's what kind of
shape you get it's not getting steeper
it's not like a cubic and falling off
the other end okay
so the gradient is decreasing
now what what do we say here okay
um you have to be careful because some
of you will say i actually heard both
answers some will say at an increasing
rate
but some of you will say at a decreasing
rate
which one is it
now i'm not going to answer that
question at the moment part of the
reason why is because it's just a
sementic difficulty okay if you wanted
to you could kind of justify either
answer depending on what you meant by
increasing or decreasing okay
you always want to try and make your
communication in all fields not just
maths as unambiguous as possible so
can we say in a more specific way
the grading is decreasing
but it's doing in a
way that you know uh let's see what's
happening about this guy
again i'm going to ask the question
what's happening as you go from this way
to negative infinity
okay what's happening to the gradient
what's the gradient i'm just thinking
about the gradient at this exact point
zero what might the gradient be here
how does it look maybe like it's not
quite 45 degrees is it maybe it's like
minus two-thirds or something like that
okay if i go a little further you know
that looks like the tangent might be 45
so maybe that's minus one
okay and maybe minus three or you get
the idea as i go this way i am
decreasing aren't i
the gradient is decreasing okay because
it's getting more and more negative
but
this kind of behavior is totally
different to this kind of behavior so
can we come up with a better way to say
it okay a more accurate less ambiguous
way okay
now i'll spare you it i won't always
give you annoying questions that i don't
answer okay i think probably the easiest
way to say it is
as x approaches negative infinity okay
i'm using this limit language very
deliberately right
the gradient
actually yeah notation for that do you
want a dx right
it's approaching something as well
unlike this see this this is not
approaching anything it's going to keep
on going more and more negative forever
okay no no limits but here this does go
toward a limit namely zero
okay i suppose if we wanted to tie it
all up together in one um
in one sentence one mathematical
sentence we could say the limit as x
approaches negative infinity of d y on
dx that limit is zero
okay so those two things are the same
okay
good now
what does the gradient function actually
look like okay i went around and i saw
lots of different things
but basically your gradient function
looked a lot like your original function
which is correct okay it is
now i'm going to draw in my best shot at
the gradient function don't forget this
is 2 to the x okay i want you to compare
mine to yours what way is it similar
what is it different here's what i've
got
uh that's often you'll have to do
yeah
so this graph underneath
okay
that's um
d y on dx
okay now you'll notice a few things
number one
my grading is my grading function is
below the original function okay who
drew theirs like that anyone
maybe i should ask who actually got to
join one hands up
what did i see i must have seen your 3dx
ah come on for you to class you did
better than that
okay
it's below right i wonder where you
might have drawn it some of you might
have drawn it above it would still
behave according to the rules you just
set right
you also notice it's not like three to
the x this is missing a crucial feature
that three to the x had okay during
three dx and two dx they shared this
intercept remember that what was that
because anything to the power of zero is
always going to be one okay
but this is not i very deliberately put
it underneath okay why
you can get to that shot okay
the last thing is it's underneath it
stays underneath forever and it's
approaching underneath in a way that
is mirroring the kind of rate at which
to the x is 3dx didn't do that do you
remember 3 to the x sort of hugged the
asymptote a lot more tightly okay
because we said it grows faster it also
shrinks faster okay because it's all at
the base three
five a hundred the bigger that number is
the more extreme its behavior is okay